FHIR solutions are built from a set of
modular components called resources.
The FHIR resources are a subset of RIM,
essentially the most important and
most commonly used data constructs,
organized and categorized as shown here.
I suggest you visit the resources
section of the FHIR website to
further explore this
key element of FHIR.
These resources can easily be assembled
into working systems that more quickly
and easily solve real world clinical and
administrative problems.
FHIR is suitable for a wide
variety of contexts as shown here.
This might include mobile phone apps,
cloud communications,
EHR based data sharing,
server communication in large and
institutional health care provider
settings and other environments.
The key is the use of FHIR resource
tags in the underlying data structures.
The interaction between the systems and
the databases is via restful APIs
which are relatively easy and
fast to implement, further facilitating
innovation and development.
As we discussed earlier,
a similar web-services approach was
specified by Healthy Decisions.
The web-services paradigm is
increasingly seen as the best vehicle
for developing and more rapidly
deploying interoperability solutions and
even analytic routines, and
services such as those required for
clinical decision support.
This is an important trend that
I strongly encourage you to
follow over time.